donald trump scores an ace but he's too
modest to rub it in your face
yeah the former perez hits a perfect
shot but he's not one to brag a lot and
said he finished the hole in one stroke
then trolled the media with a joke
did a perfect swing have trump yelling
four
more years
when people doubted republican candidate
tim swains claimed that former president
donald trump shot a hole in one trump
just stayed quiet didn't bother to
defend himself kidding he issued a
formal statement via his website fax
smoke signal and carrier pigeon
quote many people are asking so i'll
give it to you now it is 100 true he
said adding that the shot had sailed
magnificently into a rather strong wind
he's really a better writer than
hemingway
he added that his shot on that hole was
better than the golf pros he was playing
with but wouldn't say who won because he
was too humble quote i won't tell you
who won because i'm a very modest
individual and you will say then that i
was bragging
and i don't like people who brag
that's one humble brag so with the times
admitting hunter's laptop is real and
polls showing he'd win handling a biden
rematch rematch
along with this hole in one it's a good
time to be donald trump although sources
say adam schiff plans to form a
committee to investigate the golf shot
which cnn has called both racist and a
threat to democracy as we know it
i want to go to i should go to a family
member first tyrus
no kidding eric eric
he's a good writer
i actually i mean it's like he can write
something that can like make the people
who understand him laugh and the people
that don't understand him angry it's the
greatest troll right into the slight
wind with a slight break on the green
and by the way he's writing this just i
mean he's clearly laughing when he's
writing this
but you know what honestly it actually
speaks to who donald trump is right we
used to have a cheerleader in this
country and we'd have a cheerleader for
the united states for our economy for
companies for law enforcement for our
military for our vets for everything
that we love about the u.s u.s was
number one to donald trump at absolutely
everything we did now the problem is we
don't have a cheerleader in this country
anymore and it's actually when you see a
statement like that where he's
cheerleading something he cares about
like that's really ingrained in his dna
he cares about golf he loves it and he
was having fun doing it but
it actually signifies something much
more like we need somebody to cheerlead
for our nation again and i'm sick and
tired of not having that
well i'm here for you
tyrus
cyrus do you ever golf yeah i mean i
don't do it now i top golf with my kids
because i just like going yard and have
them give me praises that's when you hit
it out of the park greg it's a baseball
term cat
but i've had a hole in one before i have
one in college it's pretty easy isn't it
it's it's a life-changing event it
really it's pretty easy a hole-in-one
everyone cheers for you people who
doesn't know you the guy who was telling
you you were going too slow suddenly
wants to wan do everything you do when
you walk in hand in your car when they
look at your car they're like oh my this
guy you gotta oh my god hey buy him a
beer like it is a great thing cocktails
yeah it's it's a great moment so he he
should enjoy that considering the damage
that he did at the academy awards let's
not forget yes let's not let this hole
in one slide he did cause violence
that's true he normalized violence
normalized violence at the catamaran
because one thing we know about
president trump is he's good for a
backhand i don't know how many times we
saw him putting hands on somebody in the
office you know i mean
poor i mean
just that eric test is heavy-handed but
yeah so let's and let him have
the the holy one for a moment but i
guarantee you there's there's some blogs
coming you know uh racist grass
he's normalizing hole-in-ones which is a
problem i have a friend who has nine
holes in one a guy named buzz oh so it
can't be that hard if you play golf
every single day it's kind of weird if
you don't have holes hole at once that's
nothing on kim jong-un who had nine in
one round that's right
that is true if you recall yes uh i mean
listen i'm impr i've never had a hole in
one i've i've played a lot of mini golf
ah and i've had some hole-in-ones there
which i'm quite proud of i'd love to see
you play miniature golf very cool would
you drape yourself on an american flag
absolutely
chants all over the course yes
he didn't just say slight breeze he said
a rather strong wind
ball bounced twice
went clank yeah
into the hole
that is i'm telling you it's better than
me cummings yes and you what you said is
so right he writes it because the people
who know him and love him enjoy it and
the people who hate him can't handle it
you know i bet you would best be
conflicted at a peewee golf course when
you get to the windmill because you're
going to be like i'm not for wind power
and you'd how would you play
i don't know a good point it's a good
point i would boycott dive poor guy
would walk around that hole do you have
you ever touched a golf club
oh i went golfing was yeah was it a date
no it was
i was i was like with it was me my uncle
and my brother and i didn't make any of
the holes
[Laughter]
no matter how hard i tried
and then i cried so hard all afternoon
and i thought i can never ever have a
job that requires me to go golfing with
my colleague because i certainly can't
behave this way
i don't think i can behave any
differently
that's
well that's well you know where you came
far despite not being able to horrible
sobbing he was making fun of me snot
everywhere
wow regular spalding but i've moved past
it i mean not the snot i still snot a
lot but yeah it's okay that's right my
eyes are watering i have algaes
where am i oh up next sex drugs and
degradation from the place where they
pass legislation